what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing
what's the meaning of life
wow
it's in your name as we talked about you
have to have to live up do you feel
the requirement to have to live up to
your name
because live yeah
no because i don't see it i mean my
well again it's kind of like
no i don't know
because my full name is olivia yeah so i
can retreat in that and be like oh
olivia what does that even mean um
live up to live uh
no i i can't say i i do because i've
never thought of it that way okay and
then your name backwards is evil that's
what i also talked about
there's there's like layers i mean i i
feel the urge to to live up to that to
be to be the inverse of evil yeah um or
even better because i don't think you
know
is the inverse of evil good or is good
something completely
separate to that
i think my intuition says it's the
latter but i don't know anyway again
getting in the weeds um what is the
meaning of all this uh of life
um why are we here
i think to
explore have fun and understand
um and make more of here and to keep the
game going
here more more of more of
this whatever this is more of experience
just to have more of experience and
ideally positive experience
um and
more
complex you know to i guess try and put
it into a sort of vaguely scientific
term um
make it so that the program required the
length of code required to describe the
universe is as long as possible
uh and you know highly complex and
therefore interesting
because again like
i know you know we bang the the
the metaphor to death but like
tiled with
x you know told with uh paper clips
doesn't require that much of a code to
describe um obviously maybe something
emerges from it but at that steady state
assuming a steady state it's not very
interesting whereas
it seems like our universe is over time
becoming more and more complex and
interesting there's so much richness and
beauty and diversity on this earth and i
want that to continue and get more i
want more
more diversity and in the very best
sense of that word um
is i to me the
the the the goal of all this uh yeah
yeah and somehow
have fun in the process yes
because we do create a lot of fun things
along instead of in this
creative force
and all the beautiful things we create
somehow there's like a
funness to it and perhaps that has to do
with the finiteness of life the
finiteness of all these experiences
which is what makes them kind of unique
like the fact that they end there's this
uh whatever it is
falling in love or um
creating a piece of art
or creating a bridge
or
creating a rocket or creating a
i don't know just the the businesses
that do that that that build something
or
solve something
the fact that it is born and it dies
um somehow
embeds it with
fun with joy
for the people involved i don't know
what that is
the finiteness of it it can do some
people struggle with the you know i mean
a big
thing i think that one has to learn is
is being okay with things coming to an
end
and
uh
in terms of like some projects and so on
right people cling on to things beyond
what they're meant to be doing you know
beyond what make is reasonable
um
and i'm gonna have to come to terms with
this podcast coming to an end i really
enjoy talking to you i i think it's
obvious as we've talked about many times
you should be doing a podcast you should
you're already doing
a lot a lot of stuff publicly to the
world which is awesome and you're a
great educator you're a great mind
you're a into like but it's also this
whole medium of just talking it is good
it's a fun one it's it really is good
and it's it's just
it's nothing but like oh it's just so
much fun
and you can just get into so many
yeah there's the space to just explore
and and see what comes and and emerges
and yeah yeah to understand yourself
better and if you're talking to others
to understand them better yeah and
together with them i mean i you should
do your you should do your own podcast
but you should also do a podcast with c
as you talked about that the two of you
have such
uh
different minds that like melt together
in just hilarious ways fascinating ways
just uh the tension of ideas there is
really powerful but in general i think
you you got a beautiful voice so thank
you thank you so much for talking today
thank you for being a friend thank you
for honoring me with this conversation
with your valuable time thanks liv thank
you
you